اذا اكثر من عشرين مليون معتمر في الحرمين
الشريفين منذ بدايه شهر رمضان وقفتنا
المسائيه الاولى من الحرمين الشريفين مع
الزميلين اسامه القاسم من مكه المكرمه
وسلطان السلمي من المدينه المنوره اهلا
بكما وابداء معك ننتقل في البدايه الى مكه
ينضم الينا مراسلنا من هناك السماء القاسم
اسامه اهلا بك كيف هي اجواء العشر الاواخر
من الشهر الفضيل خاصه مع تدفق اعداد كبيره
من الراغبين في اداء العمره في هذا الوقت
بالتحديد من رمضان
اهلا نادين اهل السهام تحيه طيبه عليكما
ولجميع مشاهدين مسائل العربيه انقل لكم
الصوت والصور اليوم من هنا من احدى ساحات
المسجد الحرام التي تشهد الان ازدحاما
شديدا حيث يدخل الزوار وقاصده المسجد
الحرام الى صحن المطاف لاداء مناسك العمره
وايضا الصلاه في جميع ساحات ومداخل الحرم
المكي الشريف اترككم الان في صوره مباشره
مع الزميل اجمل حول هذه الاعداد الغفيره
التي نشاهدها الان نعم اذا اكثر من 20
مليون زائر ومعتمر خلال العشرين اليوم او
العشرين اليوم الاولى التي نتحدث عنها
اليوم بحكم اننا نتحدث عن العشر الاواخر
اليوم وما هي التجهيزات التي سوف تشهدها
مكه المكرمه بالتحديد في المسجد الحرام
لاستقبال هذه الاعداد المليونيه الى
الرئاسه شؤون الحرمين اعلنت عن 950 الف
زائر ومعتمر في اليوم الواحد اي ما يقارب
الى يومنا هذا اكثر من 20 مليون زائر
ومعتمر تقدم لهم كافه الخدمات الانسانيه
والطبيه
والخدميه في جميع مداخل وساحات المسجد
الحرام اذا ايضا نتحدث عن التوسعه
السعوديه الثالثه التي تتسع لاكثر من
مليون و200 الف مصلي واعلنت دراسه شؤون
الحرمين وجميع الجهات المسانده والوكالات
الموجوده عن رفع الجاهزيه القصوى لاستقبال
هذه الاعداد المليونيه للزوار
والمعتمرين اذا هذه المشاعر التي نشاهدها
هذه الاعداد الغفيره من قوافل الزوار
والمعتمرون التي نشاهدها الان هنا في
الحرم المكي هذا المشهد الاسر الذي نراه
جميعا عبر الشاشات وهنا تحديدا في مسائل
العربيه نتحدث عنه بشكل اوسع عن الخدمات
التي تقدم لهم اكثر من 30 مليون لتر من
سقيا زمزم تم تقديمها للزوار والمعتمرين
اكثر ايضا من ثلاثه ملايين ونصف مليون
مستفيد من جميع الخدمات الميدانيه
المتواجده في جنبات المسجد الحرام تم
تخصيص سته مداخل للدخول الى صحن المطاف
وتم تخصيص سته مداخل ايضا لاداء الصلو
نتحدث اليوم عن امتلاء الساحات وهذه
الساحه الشرقيه كما نشاهدها الان ممتلئه
باعداد الزوار والمعتمرين اذا نادين سهام
نحن نتحدث هنا في وسط هذا المشهد بالتاكيد
هذه المشاعر الاسره الجميع اليوم يشعر
بهذه الفرحه بحكم انه يصل الى المسجد
الحرام ايضا السلطات السعوديه قدمت كل
الدعم لان يعيش هذا الزائر والمعتمد تجربه
استثنائيه وان يعيش ويقدم ويؤدي مناسك
العمره بكل يسر وسهوله وطمانينه بالفعل
اسامه نحن نعيش معك اجواء العشر الاواخر
من الحرم المكي المسجد الحرام خلينا نذهب
سويا الى المدينه المنوره ومن هناك سلطان
السلمي لنطلع على اجواء العشره الاواخر في
المدينه المنوره من مسجد النبوي حيث انت
اهلا بكم واهلا بكافه مشاهدي مساء العربيه
حتى هذه اللحظه سجل المسجد النبوي اكثر من
23 مصلي ومصلي وزائر وزائره قاموا باداء
الصلوات وزياره المسجد النبوي منذ اليوم
الاول من شهر رمضان نتحدث على طاقه
استيعابيه تتجاوز 340 الف مصلي ومصلي في
هذا الموسم تم تشغيل كافه الطاقه
التشغيليه القصوى او الكامله في المسجد
النبوي التحدث على الساحات والتوسعات
السعوديه الثلاث وايضا المسجد النبوي
وكذلك الاسطو ايضا نتحدث على تفعيل كافه
المبادرات والخدمات الرقميه للتسهيل على
المصلين والزوار في هذا الموسم الذي يعمل
المسجد كامل للطاقه الاستيعابيه ويعود الى
مقابر جائحه فيروس كورونا نتحدث انه اكثر
من 23 مليون مصليه مصليه ورقم كبير جدا
اريد ان اخذكم في جوله للتوه الان انتهت
صلاه المغرب وقام المصلون والمصليات
والزوار والزائرات باداء وجبات الافطار او
الافطار هنا في ساحات المسجد النبوي
[موسيقى]
الاتصال مع سلطان وكنا معكم نتابع هذه
المشاهد دائما من المسجد الحرام من مكه
المكرمه وايضا مجد نبوي في المدينه
المنوره في الايام والعشر الاواخر من
رمضان شكرا جزيلا لكما شكرا لمتابعه
المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات